c'est une journée mémorable à la
clinique 182 montréal après des années
d'efforts le travail de l'équipe
multidisciplinaire
spécialisée dans le traitement de
l'obésité infantile est récompensé par
un dos corporatif de 2 millions de
dollars c'est vraiment super beau projet
qui est porteur pour les patients
arrivés avec l'obésité c'est une cellule
très important d'avoir une bonne
éducation pour les professions de la
santé la somme servira à mettre sur pied
la première formation de niveau
universitaire sur la prise en charge
globale de l'obésité
médecins pharmaciens nutritionnistes
psychologues d'ici trois ans un grand
nombre de professionnels pourront le
recevoir on sait qu'il ya 50% de nos
professionnels de la santé pas juste ici
au québec mais partout dans le monde qui
ont des préjugés défavorables à l'égard
de cette maladie là et c'est important
aussi de savoir que 50% d'entre eux
rapportent ne pas avoir eu de formation
depuis 2010 l'équipe du docteur saint
pierre qui compte trois cliniques
étaient de revenus auprès de plusieurs
milliers de patients c'est pas pour rien
qu'elle oms fait des recommandations
pour qu'on soit capable d'avoir une
approche comme celle-là c'est ses 94 %
de résultat positif s'explique par un
frein de la maladie une amélioration du
mieux être et de la santé globale de
l'enfant mariam souffrait d'un problème
de surpoids et d'un problème d'anxiété
quand elle s'est présentée à la clinique
en 2009 j'étais quelqu'un de beaucoup
renfermé sur moi-même je parlais pas
beaucoup s'étaient gênés je gardais mon
anxiété pour moi nutrition santé
physique santé mentale suivi médical les
jeunes filles mais également sa famille
ont été intégrés ou plein de traitements
mariam elle était capable d'être
outillés puis d'avoir des
stratégies pour intervenir pour air être
en mesure de retrouver sa santé trois
ans plus tard elle va beaucoup mieux
elle qui rêvait d'être infirmière vient
tout juste d'être acceptée au programme
collégial et aujourd'hui après tout ce
cheminement l'heure
chez une issue positive souriante je
m'ouvre au monde puis je fais encore d
un bon cheminement pour continuer comme
ça on estime que le tiers des jeunes
canadiens et au total plus de 500
millions de jeunes dans le monde
souffrent d'un problème de surpoids ou
d'obésité ici norma grondin radio canada
montréal